para analizar este y otros temas
relacionados con fútbol le damos la
bienvenida a Sara Castro directora del
diario Ash Colombia y directora de
deportes en Caracol radio bienvenida
Sara como siempre un gusto estar con
ustedes
Sara Tenemos que hablar de Este título
para Uruguay será este la piedra angular
de un proyecto serio para buscar la copa
del mundo en 2026 o en 2030 que hay del
proceso de Marcelo Broly y qué le podría
imprimir a los jugadores de la sub-20 la
llegada de Marcelo bielsa la selección
absoluta pues Luis la verdad es muy
llamativo que una selección como la
uruguaya no hubiese conseguido antes un
título sub-20 como este los primeros
campeones del mundo y sobre todo un país
que siempre ha sido exportador de
talentos un país de 3 millones que es
conocido en el mundo justo por la
categoría y calidad de sus futbolistas
Me parece que lo que broli logró a
partir además de ese título de con
peñarol en la Libertadores sub-20
es incorporar también esta nueva
estructura del fútbol uruguayo en la
cual el talento ya no solo se
caracteriza por esa garra y esas
condiciones defensivas o de lucha
siempre en la disputa de los partidos
sino que tiene muchísimo talento y sin
duda el complejo Celeste y lo que él
representa siempre ha estado muy
presente en eso no en la identidad del
fútbol uruguayo mientras estuvo el
maestro tabares al frente de la
selección él era el encargado de generar
ese vínculo entre las diferentes
selecciones juveniles el incluso vio
llegar a jugadores como Valverde y los
hizo debutar en la selección de mayores
yo siento que bielsa viene a
complementar esto él es un hombre que
siempre se caracteriza si bien no por
liderar este proyecto de juveniles y por
dar unas líneas muy claras sobre lo que
es necesario en términos de estructura
en la formación y siento que va a ser
muy positivo ya en esta primera
convocatoria para los partidos amistosos
que se disputarán en fecha FIFA citó a
siete jugadores Sub 20 Así que esto
habla una vez más de seguramente veremos
un Uruguay mucho más protagonista es
rarísimo no hablar de un primer campeón
ya había estado en una final frente
Argentina en el 97 está Argentina
dirigida por José pekerman con Juan
Román riquelme aimar y otros grandísimos
jugadores incluso Leonel scaloni y luego
en 2013 estuvo muy cerca ante la
selección de Francia de Pogba en la que
pierden en penales Así que insisto creo
que Uruguay va por muy buen camino
interesante lo que podremos lograr con
este proyecto Pero llegó el momento de
hablar de la Champions League que fue
ganada por el Manchester City Sara Qué
significa Este título para el club para
la Premier League y también para josep
Guardiola es muy es muy llamativo
también no 2008 llega el abu dhabi
United Group este grupo inversor de
emiratos árabes a hacerse con el equipo
y este puede ser uno de los argumentos
en contra de este proyecto no un
proyecto de muchísimo dinero pero creo
que lo que ha demostrado esto es que
cuando se quiere llegar lejos o
conseguir resultados de este tipo Hay
que ser consecuente creo que esto es lo
que ha hecho el City en 2011 consiguió
la primera fake Up en digamos en este
nuevo en este nuevo ciclo Y a partir de
ahí lo que ha hecho es empezar a crecer
y a crecer en identidad no una identidad
que logran forjar y sobre todo cimentar
a través de la figura de Pep Guardiola
un hombre que no solo es influyente en
el campo sino también en eso no en poder
transformar Una institución a los
valores e identidad que ya tenía el city
él incorporó otros más que le permiten
hoy en día hacer el campeón de Europa
Me parece que Pep Guardiola ha sido muy
cuestionado después de sus años en el
Barcelona porque siempre se ha sentido
como un entrenador que ha tenido todos
los recursos a su disposición pero
siento además que con este vínculo que
logró con este grupo inversor con este
estos presidentes y directivos del club
es convencer a la gente de que los
pequeños fracasos o las derrotas son
apenas un Punto de partida para volver a
empezar un ciclo ganador
guardo le hizo mejora muchos jugadores
esto lo demuestra la figura de Rodri en
los partidos definitivos de esta
temporada Así que siento que es un
premio más a mí no me gusta rankear a
los entrenadores pero la influencia de
Pep Guardiola ya lo dije desde el punto
de vista futbolístico creo que lo que ha
logrado como entrenador en un en unos
años en los que ha transformado o por lo
menos Ha logrado revalidar su concepto
del fútbol Ha logrado influir también en
muchísimos otros entrenadores y
entrenadores y formadores alrededor del
mundo ahora ya hablaremos de los
italianos que también tienen lo suyo Sí
precisamente ahí iba mi próxima pregunta
porque el inter no pudo quedarse con el
título y cierra un capítulo negativo
para un país que alcanzó tres finales en
torneo continentales Pero no logró ganar
lo que vimos este año es un resurgir del
fútbol italiano o debemos esperar unas
temporadas más para hablar de ello las
últimas temporadas ya nos han demostrado
lo primero es que el fútbol italiano
necesitaba
tomar esa estructura ellos venían de
unas crisis económicas que evidentemente
habían afectado el rendimiento de los
clubes a nivel internacional pero siento
que esto hace parte de
un análisis que también se ha hecho en
torno al calcio de que estaba pasando ya
hemos hablado de las eliminaciones de la
selección de mayores y como esto genera
digamos que todo un debate en torno a
qué tiene que ser el fútbol italiano y
esto incluso nos lleva a hablar de la
sub-20 que también llegó a la final no
Entonces estamos hablando de un calcio
que se da cuenta que si bien había
priorizado durante muchos años la
táctica y el orden también tenía que
preocuparse por formar sus jugadores y
por eso vemos en esta sub-20 jugadores
con más características totalmente
diferentes en canchas enganches
encaradores muy picantes con otro tipo
de características que creo que vienen a
a fortalecer el fútbol italiano en ese
sentido siento que el fútbol italiano de
los últimos años le ha dado la
oportunidad a entrenadores que muestran
otro otro tipo de estilos de fútbol
siento que lo de insaggie lo demuestra
totalmente fue un equipo que
emocionalmente superó al City en el
primer tiempo y que además Tuvo más
goles esperados más remates al arco es
decir que se impuso a través de otras
características diferentes a lo que
normalmente era conocido como El
catenazo Así que siento que si es un
resurgir del fútbol italiano y que tal
como hablábamos de Pep Guardiola hay que
darle tiempo para que logre consolidar
esto en resultados Muchísimas gracias
Sara por este amplio análisis del mundo
del fútbol